[Music]
let's go to cali in
bowling green going back to kelly what's
up
hey dr john how are you we are rocking
on to the brigadon how about you
i'm wonderful i just want to say i'm
super thankful for everything that you
brought to our community and that you
put out there i'm one of the ogs yes
i've been listening since episode one so
one of the original 17.
yes yes thank you so much i'm
i'm
i'm deeply grateful thank you
no problem so what's up so
um i'm calling today because i coach a
high school volleyball team and that
comes with its own challenges
we have been really struggling on
teaching our girls how to communicate
with one another
and on top of that learning to be
vulnerable on top of the communicating
piece
yeah i just wanted your advice on how to
kind of facilitate that with high school
girls
as a former high school i'm just kidding
so i thought you were about to say hey
we're struggling on offense and i was
gonna have to tell you i don't really
know how volleyball works i just know
that you all they go on a line so good
this one's an easier question for me to
answer
um
and i used to be a high school coach too
and it's one of my favorite jobs i've
ever ever had so good for you are you
enjoying it do you like the influence in
their life
i absolutely love it i have a full-time
job year-round but this is something
that i also do year-round we coach high
school
from july to october and then i turn
around and coach club ball for the same
high school girls um from december until
may
they're never in
yeah exactly okay so here's what i've
seen and working with high school and
college kids over the last couple
decades i've seen in a way that i don't
think most adults most 35 and 45 year
olds and and older
fully grasp
just how much
relationship has moved on into digital
exchanges
like even asking like my middle schooler
and his all his friends like when you go
with somebody right you give a
girlfriend
you never even make eye contact you
don't see each other it's all text and
photos and emojis like everything's been
outsourced there and so you're getting a
lot of information but
it's it's interesting i haven't talked
to a high school coach but it doesn't
surprise me that then when they get in a
real life situation where they have to
basically read each other's minds and
know i'm going to be here in this space
and you gotta look at my body position
and i've got to holler at you and say
hey go go go
their brains don't just shut down right
so give me an example of of
situations where there's
they're not being vulnerable where they
need to communicate better um give me an
example that
so i'll kind of give you a little bit of
a background um
last season this is probably the most
talented group i've ever coached hands
down they're very young primarily
sophomores
we have a few seniors that kind of lead
the group but even some of them are
struggling with communication
but we've
started working with a sports
psychologist last year she did wonderful
work um
but we of course were unable to afford
her this year high school budget
volleyball doesn't make that cut way to
go america
very very much so so i've kind of tried
to step in that role and start doing
some small and large group activities
with them after practice
just to learn to communicate off the
court hoping that it will transfer
onto the court
so on the court they're just having
issues where they literally will not
talk
to each other they're running into each
other something will happen
and ss coaches feel like we're having to
spoon feed them everything to say and do
gotcha and they are physically capable
of knowing exactly what to do and what
to say but
it's just that awkwardness that tension
and even
some of the small group activities we've
been doing with them
after practice
to get them to open up to each other to
even say something they like about
themselves
it's like
terrible it's so awkward yeah
do not feel comfortable whatsoever
um
okay so let's
back all the way out ultimately there's
two things at play one there's trust and
one there is just a skill set okay
i do believe that we're gonna have hell
to pay because we're gonna have a
generation of people that don't have the
skills to communicate in person with one
another
right and i think we're you're you're
experiencing like i don't even know how
to tell you that i'm uncomfortable i can
text it to you i can dm you let you know
how i'm feeling
but i can't say that to you right and
for you and me who's grew up saying it
first and texting it second
that feels insane but that's the reality
right
the second one is trust and here's
i think you earn trust three one of
three ways if not all three play
sharing meals and shared experiences
i've got to know you're going to be
there and i have to have these
exchanges over food over play
that is going to allow me to then my
brain to feel safe enough to say hey i
don't think i look good in this or i
don't like the way you talk to me on the
court right so i've got to set a context
and so i'd love to
reframe it
and these aren't adjunct things so even
the language like we do these things
after practice
i would love for you to include them
into practice
this is a part of who we are
um and i'm thinking back to little
things that my coaches have made like we
had a weekly team dinner during the
season
um where we'd all get together um i'm
gonna send you every single deck of
questions for humans that i got okay
that would be amazing thank you so much
i even i started a bre i have breakfast
with my son once a week and we're doing
a book exchange and stuff
i even took them with me this last week
and they were they're a blast i'd
forgotten that i'd written some of these
questions out that we had a great time
but it allowed a different level of
conversation between me and my son when
you have a deck of cards like that when
you have some sort even if you just go
find an app i'm sure there's a million
apps out there
when you
you can point to the question ask the
car the deck of cards asks the question
not you and it makes it safer for some
reason okay it depersonalizes it in a
way but what i would recommend is saying
okay from this point forward
we're gonna cut practice short on
thursdays
by 30 minutes
because they're good right what they
need to do is learn to talk and trust
and that's gonna help accelerate their
connectivity as they function as a
single unit on the court
and but i'm gonna ask you to stay 30
minutes longer than you normally would
and we're gonna have a team dinner and
whether that's pizza or whether that's
spaghetti i think we should do spaghetti
dinners and the parents made it and
brought it and sometimes it was good and
sometimes it was a disaster
and but we shared that experience here's
another thing have you tried to go first
i have how's that going and i told them
that
i
firmly believe in
leading
by example good for you any time that i
ask them a question i answer it first
um and i've
you know probably admitted things opened
up about things that i typically
wouldn't in front of myself
but i feel like they need to see that
and they need to see a coach be
vulnerable yes um my problem is i'm only
an assistant i'm one of four coaches
okay and their head coach is a male and
he's very good friend of mine
and he
would never participate in this
so i guess that's a twofold i
i'm the only one kind of steer heading
this and i've got a great relationship
with the girls because of it
but to get him and the other coaches
involved
is a challenge of its own
why won't he play
um he
just full honesty comes off with the his
job is to win games yep okay which i
understand um but i do too
i feel like you have to connect that's
exactly right so he's playing a very
short game right he's like a modern
corporation that's like i gotta make
more earnings in this quarter and they
forget that they're playing a long game
right and so you can earn you can sprint
and sprint and sprint eventually your
company's gonna go away very similar
um he's gonna win some games out of some
talented kids and he's gonna move on to
a new place and leave these kids there
um
that's hard okay i wish there was an
easy i've worked with head coaches
they're hard it's hard there's a lot of
ego there there's a lot of this is my
team and that language right this is my
group of humans that i
run and own and whatever
um that's gonna be hard i think the best
you can do is just be the positive
influence that you can and it might
would he be a part would he support team
dinners would he support team play or
cut and practice short or does it all
have to be something you do after he
gets done with his practice
um i think i could convince him we're
really like we went to college together
we're close friends so he's very
stubborn but i could probably get
through to him eventually okay
here's where team dinners are important
on thursdays we do team dinners there
are no electronics allowed none zero
everyone's gonna make it um on monday it
for as a warm-up or the first thing we
do
we're gonna do some crazy agility drill
that is team driven
coaches will not participate there's an
over-coaching that's happening with
young young athletes also
that every move is prescriptive
this idea that they're going to go play
then we don't do that anymore because we
got to win games and by winning games
i'm going to give you this play and
you've got to run this play in this way
and
so they literally don't know how to take
a next step because every step has been
prescribed for them since they were
three years old
and there's something about letting them
just go we're gonna give you five
minutes so y'all figure this game out
and this is how this game works and
here's the four coaches and we're going
to demonstrate how it goes
and y'all are competing against this
other you know the you know the a
squad's going to participate against the
or compete against the b squad we're
going to make them do some of these
things but we're not going to over coach
them we're going to back out a little
bit
okay and i was the worst
the
worst this is the pot talking the kettle
here
man every mistake my first year of
coaching every mistake i called out
you threw the ball away you did it and
it rem
after my first year i had some coaches
lean into me a little bit because i was
a young hot-headed knuckle-headed [ __ ]
and they said dude
you know who knows that they just
dribbled that ball off their knee into
the stands more than anybody that kid
you yelling it across the uh
gym isn't helpful
he knows you know what i mean
right and that was such a good reminder
especially in practice to
dial back my coaching and dial up my
engagement
meaning i'm gonna be much more
relational and less i see that when i
see that when i see that see what i'm
saying i'm gonna coach effort i'm gonna
coach spacing i'm gonna coach paying
attention much more than move over left
go up you see what i'm saying
right and i don't know if that's going
on in your practices that sure went on
at my practice man because i was just
over coaching and i paralyzed the kids
when i did that and by the way if you're
listening to this you're not a coach all
of this applies to parenting
we over parent and we over like hey you
got this you do this you got this you do
this you got your deodorant you brush
your teeth did you get your shoes get
today just today
my son left his track shoes his
cross-country shoes
and inside and i asked my wife as i was
leaving me run these to the school it's
20 minutes out of the way this way and i
got to go 20 minutes back she said no
he'll just have to do practice in
whatever shoes he's wearing and that's
probably going to be a very
uncomfortable three mile run in the
woods
and i assure you he's going to remember
his shoes right this is just the way we
move forward right
oh man all right so kelly hang on the
line here i'm going to send you all of
the questions for humans cards and by
the way if you have people in your life
whether they're teens adults um
couples you just started dating you've
been dating a long time you've been
married a long time
there's cards for everybody girls night
guys night friends just hanging out
having chips and queso and having a few
beers whatever it is
grab these cards they're tools to teach
us again how to have in-person
communication how to have in-person
conversations and man all over the
planet people are writing and saying
these things are changing their families
and changing their friendships
go pick some up johnny.com